[SQUEAKING] [RUSTLING]
[CLICKING] MARKUS KLUTE:
Welcome back to 8.701.
We're starting a new
chapter now, Chapter 9,
on nuclear physics.
And this video is the
first introduction
into the topic,
where I'm explaining
some of the terminology
and some of the concepts.
We dive in much more
detail as we go on.
So given an atom, you can
specify the number of neutrons,
the number of protons,
and the number
of electrons, which is equal
to the number of protons,
for neutral atoms.
Atoms of the same element, they
have the same atomic number,
Z, but they're not all the same.
Isotopes of the same element
have different numbers
of neutrons.
So we can have uranium with
a number of neutrons varying.
You typically write an
isotope by specifying
the mass, the number of protons,
and the number of neutrons.
But that information
is redundant.
So typically, we simplify
this by just writing things
like 238 uranium,
and that specifies
a specific isotope of uranium.
When talking about
different nuclei,
we sometimes refer
to them as nuclide,
atom/nucleus with a
specific number of neutrons
and a specific
number of protons.
Isobars are nuclides
with the same mass,
with the same number, same
sum of protons and neutrons,
but with varying individual
number of protons and neutrons.
An isotine is a nuclide with
the same number of neutrons,
but with varying
number of protons,
and an isomer is
the same nuclide
but different
[? eigen ?] states,
which means that the
energy states are--
an energy state.
So we can excite nuclides at
their component particles.
The nuclear radius
typically can be extracted
from the mass of the nuclide.
And it's simply we add
little balls to the sum,
and it scales with A to the
1/3 the mass of a number
of elements in this nuclide.
There's many isotopes.
There's many nuclides.
And so you typically can look
at all of them, if you want,
or a subset of them
in nuclear charts
that's given here, where we
plot here the number of protons,
and here the number of neutrons.
And we look at many more
of those charts later.
Here's another representation
of the very same thing.
You see a nuclear chart again.
And here, what's spotted in
red are the stable nuclei.
We will see that
nuclei can decay,
and we'll understand why
they decay and in what form
they decay.
It's a core part
of this chapter,
understanding how
nuclei can decay,
and what we can learn about
them by studying their decays.
One way to look at
it, for example,
we see that here I
plot Z over A, so
the number of protons over the
sum of the number of protons, Z
plus N. And you see that
most of the stable nuclei,
with the exception of the one
with very small mass number,
have less protons than neutrons.
So there's an
excess of neutrons.
This can also be seen here.
The stable nuclei are
typically on or below this axis
where Z is equal to A.
Radioactive decays can be
characterized, typically,
as a parent nuclide, and
then a daughter nuclide.
And so radioactive
decay is a process
in which an unstable nucleus
spontaneously loses energy
by emitting
particles, ionization
particles and radiation.
The decay and the loss
of energy results, then,
in an atom of one type, the
parent particle or parent
nuclide, transforming into
another type of an atom,
or the daughter nuclide.
We have already
looked at decay rate
in the concept of particle
physics interactions,
but we can define this very
similar here, the decay rate,
or sometimes it is
called decay constant.
And then as we
did before, we can
define the mean lifetime or the
half life of a parent nuclide.
So this is it for
the introduction.
And in the next lecture, we'll
start looking in the energy
which is used to bind
the nuclei, the protons
and neutrons together, and
how we can understand this
from an empirical model.